tras un corto respiro las llamas vuelven
a arder en bolivia arrasando con varias
áreas protegidas y ecosistemas diversos
como el de la chiquitanía del pantanal y
bosques de la amazonía los departamentos
de santa cruz y de cochabamba fueron los
más afectados a todos los bomberos sepan
que el pueblo cruceño está agradecido
por el trabajo compromiso y esfuerzo que
realizan para combatir el fuego y
protegernos de los incendios gracias por
su heroica labor los daños para la flora
y la fauna son incalculables en roboré
en el departamento de santa cruz se
instaló un refugio para animales pero
para algunos como estos dos jaguares la
ayuda ha llegado demasiado tarde
mientras que un tejón que se encontraba
sediento en su hábitat devastado fue
rescatado por unos bomberos voluntarios
con mucha sed hemos dado
con la naturaleza lo que quiera la
naturaleza que si no
tenemos protección para los animales
las llamas suelen ser iniciadas por
agricultores y ganaderos que buscan
aumentar el rendimiento de sus tierras
pero debido a las condiciones muy secas
y al viento se salen rápidamente de
control
según la fundación amigos de la
naturaleza de enero a julio al menos 700
49 mil hectáreas fueron quemadas por
incendios en bolivia el equivalente de
más de mil millones de campos de fútbol